اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم مشاهدينا نبدا
بالعناوين
حرب المسيرات تشتعل بين موسكو وكيف فصل
جديد من فصول الحرب في عامها الثاني
[تصفيق]
البرهان في احدث ظهور له ينفي تصريحات
قوات الدعم السريع بمحاربه جماعه الاخوان
[تصفيق]
اخر يوم لنا في مهمتنا العظيمه تقريبا
وصلنا لاخر
رائد الفضاء السعوديان ريان وعلي ودعان
المحطه الدوليه في طريق عودتهما الى الارض
واتفاق في ليبيا على تشكيل حكومه مصغره
لسته اشهر لتنظيم الانتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه
اذا مشاهدينا موسكو وكيف بين مد وجزر
روسيا تشن هجوما جويا باحدى وثلاثين مسيره
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه اسقطت القوات
الاوكرانيه 29 مسيره منها طبعا هذا بحسب
كيف بدورها ردت باطلاق ثماني مسيرات
بمنظومه
وضواحيها صباح اليوم حسبما ذكرت الدفاع
الروسيه والتي اكدت بدورها ان دفاعاتها
الجويه قد تصدت للمسيرات الاوكرانيه وايضا
دمرت جميعها قبل وصولها للعاصمه ورغم
تدميرها الا ان بعضها سقط في منطقه تدعى
روبلي يوفكا غربي موسكو لكنها قريبه من
مقر اقامه بوتين الرسمي وعدد كبير من كبار
رجال الاعمال الروس وايضا كبار المسؤولين
الحكوميين وذلك بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيا مساعد الرئيس
الاوكراني نفى دور بلاده في الهجوم
بالمسيرات على موسكو المسؤول الاوكراني
اكد ان الهجوم المضاد يهدف الى العوده
لحدود 91 واستعاده القرم مشددا على وجود
فرص جديه لتحقيق اختراق عبر هجوم مضاد
وذلك خلال الصيف
[موسيقى]
طبعا ناموسكو فتحت تحقيق في الهجمات
الكشفيه عن هذه الجهات التي تنفذ الهجوم
قدوه
لجنه التحقيق يحققون في حادث تحطم طائره
بدون طيار على مبان في موسكو حيث تعرضت
العديد من المباني في موسكو لاضرار طفيفه
نتيجه تحطم طائره بدون طيار وفقا للتقارير
الاوليه لم تقع اصابات خدمات الطوارئ
بالمدينه والمحققون الجنائيون وخبراء من
دائره التحقيقات الرئيسيه بلجنه التحقيق
الروسيه في موسكو يعملون في مكان الحادث
وتم التعرف على الافراد المتورطين في
الجريمه
انه لا توجد حاليا اي تهديدات على سكان
موسكو وطبعا على ضواحيها المتحدث باسم
الكريم
في موسكو عمل بشكل فعال الكرملين حملك
مسؤوليه استهداف موسكو بالمسيرات ردا على
استهداف روسيا احدى مراكز صنع القرار في
اوكرانيا كما اكد الكرملين ان بوتين سيجري
تقييما جديدا للعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
المزيد ده انضم الينا من موسكو الينا
سوبينينا المستشاره السياسيه في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه اهلا بك من كييف معنى
مدير تحرير موقع اوكرانيا اليوم محمد
العروقي اهلا بك ايضا وابدا معك
ليناسبنينا فيما يتعلق بقراءه موسكو كيف
تنظر الى هذا الهجوم بالمسيرات كيف تقول
ان لا دخل لها بذلك هل التحقيق هذا بالفعل
يؤكد ان موسكو غير متاكده انك وراء ذلك
روسيا متاكده ان اوكرانيا وراء هذا الهجوم
مثل ما كانت روسيا متاكده ان اوكرانيا
وراء هجومات قبل
فمثلا وراء هجومات على
من اذا اوكرانيا اوكرانيا يلمحون لوجود
معارضه عسكريه روسيه هذا هذا لانه حتى نعم
هناك بعض الاشخاص تم تجنيدهم من قبل
اوكرانيا ولكن روسيا حتى لديها صور تثبت
بانه هؤلاء الاشخاص قد
التقوا في
الاسابيع الاخيره مع رئيس الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه سيد بودانه فروسيا
مئه بالمئه متاكده اوكرانيا وراء هذا
الهجوم وهذا ما قاله هو المتحدث باسم كريم
ولكن طبعا الروايه الاوكرانيه تختلف وبهذا
الاطار انتقل الى ضيفي السيد محمد سيد
محمد
كيف تقول بان لا دخل لها بهذه الاستهدافات
هل هي معنيه لمعرفه من يمكن ان يكون وراء
مثل هذه الضربات او لا
يعني تحياتي لكم وللساده المشاهدين
خلال تقريركم يعني سمعت صوت هذه الطائره
بدون طيار وتذكرت هذه الثلاث ليالي التي
قضيناها يعني تسببت بازمه نفسيه لجميع من
يسمعها في اوكرانيا او يعيش في اوكرانيا
حقيقه المشهد ثلاثه الليالي والاطفال
والجميع السكان في الكاليدورات وفي محطات
المترو من وراء هذه الطائرات هذا ما يحدث
في اوكرانيا في حين ان الطرف الاخر ينكر
تماما انه يقصف المدنيين او العاصمه كيف
ويقول انه يقصف منشات عسكريه خارج العاصمه
لا اعرف ما هي الشهاده التلفاز
والفيديوهات التي شاهدونها وايضا واقع
الحرب وواقع العمليات العسكريه معروف بس
بهمني اعرف القراءه السياسيه والتحليليه
لما يحدث الان على الارض نحن بصدد حرب
مسيرات بشكل جديد انتقام فقط لما حدث في
يوم النصر وبالتالي توقيت الان فيما يتعلق
بيوم اكياف اذا مصحه التعريف هو
الهدف بالفعل وهل بالمقابل كيف معنيه
بمعرفه تفاصيل من يقف وراء الاستهدافات
على روسيا لانه يمكن يكون في طرف ثالث
مثلا نعم يعني انا جزء ما ذكرته هو جزء
مما يحدث على الارض حقيقه الروايه الرسميه
الاوكرانيه بتماما ضلوعها في هذه العمليات
التي حدثت في موسكو صباح هذا اليوم بل ان
بعض التقارير ذهبت بان هذه الطائرات صناعه
الصينيه وتم اثبات انها صناعه الصينيه وقد
يكون طرفا ثالثا على كل حال يعني اوكرانيا
او او كيف يعني اذا حدثت هذه هذه الهجمات
فهي يعني لا تعارضها ولكن الطرف الاوكراني
ما زال ينكر ثبوته بهذه
الهجمات هذا ما اردت يعني ان اوضحه منذ
البدايه طيب بغض النظر كانت كيف وراء ذلك
او لم تكن سيده ايلينا عندما نتحدث عن ما
يحدث الان على الارض الى اين تتجه الامور
بغض النظر عن الطرف الحقيقي وراء هذه
العمليات كونه
ان تكون وراءها
تكرار لمثل هذه الهجومات على فكره
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه حول امكانيه حدوث
عمليات ارهابيه في العمق الروسي هذه
المعلومات كانت حسب علمي موجوده من قبل
ولكن الا تحرج الرئيس الروسي وعندما يقال
انه الرئيس سيعيد النظر في العمليه على
الارض ماذا نتوقع عائلنا
نتوقع ان روسيا اول شيء ستقصف
فيما بعد هي ستحاول التقدم على الارض مثل
ما تقدمت في مدينه ضخمه ولكن
الحديث حول خطه اوكرانيه بقيام بالهجوم
المضاد هي ما زالت موجوده فاذا انا روسيا
يقول زلنسكي بانه سيحدده وان كان هناك بعض
العمليات التي اتت بانها قد بدات بالفعل
بهذا الاطار سيد محمد سؤال اخير فيما
يتعلق الى اين تتجه الامور روسيا
افتتحت منشاه جديده لتصنيع ما يوصف
بالمسيرات ذات الذخائر المتسكعه هاي
بالترجمه الحرفيه العربيه كيف لموسكو ان
لكيف عذرا ان تتعامل مع هذا الوضع هل خيار
العوده ربما الى المفاوضات باي طريقه او
باخرى ليس موجود على الطاوله ابدا
يعني لا اعتقد هناك يعني رؤيه واضحه
لمفاوضات اعتقد ان السيد بوتين بطريقه
مباشره او غير مباشره يشجع الغرب ويشجع
اوكرانيا يشجع الغرب على مزيد من الدعم
لاوكرانيا اوكرانيا عندما تنقل ما يحدث
على اراضيها للغرب وتطالب بالمزيد من
المضادات الجويه والاسلحه والذخائر اعتقد
ان الغرب سيتشجع نتيجه هذه التصرفات
الروسيه الطائشه ضد اوكرانيا بمزيد من
الاسلحه نحن ذاهبون الى تصعيد خطير جدا
وخاصه في ظل الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
المرتقب مدير تحرير موقعه اوكرانيا اليوم
محمد العروقي شكرا جزيلا لك وكانت معنا من
موسكو الينا المستشاره السياسيه في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا اعلنا الرئيس الاوكراني
موافقته بشان مواعيد تحرك القوات
الاوكرانيه زيلينسكي قال بهذا الشان انه
عقد اجتماعا مع قيادات القوات المسلحه
استمع الى تقرير القائد العام وقاده
المحاور الرئيسيه واشار الى انه اصدر
موافقته على المواعيد المتعلقه بتحرك
قواته وعلى جميع القرارات بشان الهجوم
المضاد
قال ايضا ان منصات باتريوت الامريكيه تضمن
لاوكرانيا اعتراض اي صاروخ روسي بنسبه مئه
بالمئه دعونا نتابع
عندما تؤمن منصه الامريكيه بايدي
الاوكرانيين لاعتراض الكامله لاي صاروخ
الروسي بالنسبه 100% عندها سيهزم الارهاب
وبالطبع لا يوجد اذلال لدوله ارهابيه اكبر
من نجاحات محاربين في الواقع مع نجاحنا
وضغطنا ووجود الباتريوت علينا ان نستمر في
الرد على روسيا وجميع مظاهر الشر
من جهته اكد مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
في تصريحات للعربيه اكد ان الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد لا يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه
واحده بل بسلسله من العمليات الجاريه
مشيرا الى ان بعض عمليات الهجوم جاريه
وذلك منذ عده اسابيع
اما فيما يخص هجومنا ولم يحصل الان فهذا
غير صحيح لان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لا
يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده في الساعه
معينه ثم نراها على شاشه التلفزيون هذه
الهجمات المضاده هي سلسله من العمليات
الصغيره والكبيره والبعض منها جاريه منذ
عده اسابيع
هذا هو قال عمده مقاطعه انه تم استهداف
ضواحي الاقليم 220 مره خلال 24 ساعه مضيفا
ان الضربات الاوكرانيه تمثلت بصواريخ
وقذائف مدفعيه ومسيرات وعبوات ناسفه
المسؤول اشار الى تحذيرات للمواطنين من
سلطات
بضروره النزول لاقذيه المباني والملاجئ
ومن مدينه بلغراد الروسيه مراسل العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشدي ينضم الينا انقل لنا
الاجواء من عندك واخر الاخبار عبد الجواد
ميسون في الحقيقه يعني قبل وصولنا الى
مدينه بيليجراد كانت الاخبار تتوالى عن
سقوط العديد من القذائف لكن عندما تحدثنا
مع سكان هذه المدينه ومع القادمين من
المناطق الساخنه في الاقليم والمناطق
الحدوديه توضحت الصوره اكثرها اكثر الكثير
منهم يتحدث عن سقوط اكثر من 200 قذيفه
خلال كل يوم يعني كل 24 ساعه تشهدها هذه
المناطق سقوط العديد من القذايف اما
صاروخيه او مدفعيه او عبوات ناسفه تقوم
بالقائها المسيرات الوضع طبعا في مدينه هو
ساخن بشكل كبير ميسون لاخفيك حقيقه قلق
المواطنين الذين يتحدثون عن انهم يعني غير
مؤمنين نوعا ما بما يخص قضيه الاعلان
الحرب هم تعودوا على مدينتهم
بحيث ان تكون هادئه نوعا ماوى بالمناسبه
يعني تعني المدينه البيضاء لذلك طبعا سكان
هذه المدينه ينظرون الى الامور بعين
السلام كما يتحدثون لكن الوضع صراع موسكو
مع الغرب جعل من هذه المنطقه الحدوديه
ميسون الساخنه بشكل كبير اسمحي لي بان
اشير ميسون الى ان الخط الحدودي بين
مقاطعه هذه المدينه والاراضي الاوكرانيه
يمتد قرابه 400 كيلو متر لذلك عندما نلاحظ
بان الارقام التي يتحدث عنها عمده المدينه
تزيد عن 200 قذيفه يوميا ان كانت صاروخيه
او مدفعيه فهذا العدد يعتبر كبيرا بالنسبه
لهذه المناطق لابد من لفت الانتباه اين
السلطات المدينه ايضا ميسون تقوم بارسال
تفضلي ميسون تقوم بارسال تفضل
ميسون يعني لابد من التركيز على موضوع مهم
تقوم الان سلطات المدينه بارسال رسائل
نصيه عبر الهواتف المحموله لمعظم السكان
في المناطق الحدوديه هي طبعا المناطق
الغربيه والجنوبيه ابرزها يكمن في شبكينا
هذه المنطقه لها حصه الاسد من حصيله
الضربات اليوميه هذه الرسائل طبعا تاتي
للمره الخامسه يعني منذ دقائق تلقى سكان
تلك المناطق للمره الخامسه على التوالي
منذ صباح اليوم رسائل نصيه بضروره النزول
الى اقبيه المباني والى المجال الملاجئ
تحسبا لهذه الضربات لذلك طبعا الوضع هو
مقلق نوعا ما تم اجلاء العديد من سكان تلك
المناطق الجنوبيه في جنوب بيل جراد نحو
مناطق في العمق الروسي اكثر امانا لكن
حكومه البلاد حتى هذه اللحظه تتحدث عن
يعني عزمها وقيامها بحشد المزيد من القوات
على الخط الحدودي الفاصل بينها وبين اراضي
الاوكرانيه للوقوف على كل التفاصيل ومنع
تكرار ما حدث من محاوله اجتياح لاراضي
بيلغراد خلال الاسبوع الماضي طبعا الوضع
لا ينطبق يبدو في المنطقه التي تتواجد
فيها الاطفال يلعبون بارياحيه عبد الجواد
ولكن لا شك انه المناطق الحدوديه الاقرب
هي المتضرره اكثر من مدينه
الروسيه مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
شكرا جزيلا لك
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
مساء الهدنه دائمه في السودان واليونيسف
تصف وضع الاطفال في الخرطوم بالكارثه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اتفق ممثلوا
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في جده
على تمديد وقف اطلاق النار لمده خمسه ايام
طبعا بحسب ما افاد بيان مشترك للرياض
وواشنطن باعتبارهما الجانبين المياسرين
للمفاوضات بين طرفي الصراع هذا البيان
افاد بان الطرفين اتفقا على مناقشه وقف
اطلاق النار بشكل ولمده طويله الامد قد
يستلزم اخلاء القوات من المناطق الحضاريه
بما في ذلك منازل المدنيين وذكر مكتب
الشؤون الافريقيه في الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان تمديد الهدنه سيتيح الوقت لتقديم مزيد
من المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه
بيان سعودي امريكي يشير الى توقيع اتفاقيه
تمديد الهدنه بين طرفي الصراع السوداني
لمده خمسه ايام
الهدنه تهدف لاتاحه المزيد من الوقت
للجهات الانسانيه للقيام باعمالهم وحث
طرفي الصراع على احترام التزاماتهما في
التمديد الجديد
البيان اكد ان على الطرفين الالتزام
بحمايه المدنيين بالاضافه الى مناقشه وقف
اطلاق نار طويل الامد مناقشه وقف اطلاق
النار التي تستلزم اخلاء القوات من
المناطق الحضريه والمنازل وازاله العوائق
امام حريه تنقل المدنيين والمساعدات
الانسانيه وتمكين الموظفين الحكوميين من
استئناف واجباتهم المعتاده
وفي ردود الفعل رحبت منظمه التعاون
الاسلاميه باتفاق تمديد وقف اطلاق النار
الذي ذكرناه لمده خمسه ايام في السودان
عبرت عن املها في ان تكون الهدنه فرصه
لانهاء النزاع بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع
من جهه اخرى قال رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان قال ان
الجيش السوداني لم يستخدم ما وصفه بالقوه
المميته حتى الان داخل السودان قال انه
اذا اصرت قوات الدعم السريع فالجيش سيلجا
لهذه القوه البرهان اضافه ان الجيش يسيطر
على جميع المواقع العسكريه هناك بشكل كامل
والقوات الرئيسيه لا تزال على الارض كما
نفع عبد الفتاح البرهان تصريحات قوات
الدعم السريع ان الحرب في السودان ضد
جماعه الاخوان اكد رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني ان الجيش السوداني وافق على
الهدنه لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
اذا العدو من صاع وما استجاب حنضطر نستخدم
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك عمار في بدايه النشره كان
هناك عواجل تتحدث عن انه الاشتباكات عادت
خبرنا اين تتركز ان كانت لا زالت حتى الان
او اين كانت بالاحرى وكيف هو الوضع بصوره
عامه
اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم عدد هذه الاشتباكات قبل لحظات من الان
في منطقه جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم وعده مناطق
مجاوره لهذه المنطقه وايضا في شارع الغابه
وهذه المنطقه الحساسه باعتبار انها تربط
ما بين المناطق مهمه جدا داخل مدينه
الخرطوم يمكن لهذه الطرق ان تقودك الى وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا هي في محيط جسر
الفاتحاب هذا الجسر الذي يحكم الجيش
السيطره عليه ودارت فيه عده معارك منذ
ايام الهدنه الاولى ولكن هذه الاشتباكات
بحسب المصادر الميدانيه التي اشارت اليها
تشير الى انها اشتباكات متقطعه احيانا
تكون عنيفه واحيانا تكون خفيفه ما يعني ان
ليس هنالك استخدام للطيران الحربي فيها
هذه الاشتباكات هي بالمدفعيه ما بين
الجانبين وعدد من الرشاشات والعربات
العسكريه التي تتحرك في المنطقه بشكل واضح
هذا ما وردنا حتى الان ميسون بان هذه
الاشتباكات هي متقطعه ومتفرقه في مناطق
جنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم ولكن لم يتم فيها
استخدام طيران الحربي ولا حتى طائرات
الاستطلاع حتى هذه اللحظه وعمار خبرنا
عننا الشارع السوداني وكيف يعيش هذه
الايام مع هذه الهدن المستمره وان كان
بالفعل يستطيع التحرك لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه اذا مصحه التعبير
نعم بدات حركه الشارع واضحه الان مع كل
تجديد لهدنه جديده هو يبدو الامل واضحا في
ان تقف الحرب بشكل كبير ولكن حركه الشارع
الان اصبحت محدوده جدا في عدد من المناطق
وعدد من
المدن التي يستطيعون التحرك فيها داخل
الاحياء بشكل كبير حسب التقارير الطبيه
هنالك اشاره الى ان اكثر من 16 الف ممن هم
مرضى بالفشل الكلوي خرجوا الى ولايه
الجزيره وايضا كذلك عدد من مرضى القلب
وعدد من الامراض المستعصيه من الاورام
والامراض الخبيثه وما فيها ايضا تطاعوا
الخروج الى عده ولايات خاصه ولايه الجزيره
لتوفر الاجهزه الطبيه وعدد من المعينات
الطبيه على مستوى الحياه اليوميه هنالك
ندره وشحا اصبحت واضحه الان وانعدام لعدد
كبير من السلعه الدقيق والزيت ومدخلات
الحياه اليوميه في البيت السوداني على
مستوى الكهرباء والخدمات العامه والمياه
ايضا هي تتذب بين فتره واخرى وحديث
القاعده العام للجيش رئيس مجلس السيد عبد
الفتاح البرهان قبل قليل الذي نشر اشار
الى ان الهدنه الغرض منها انسان في المقام
الاول لتوصيل عدد من الخدمات والمعينات
الذين ما زالوا يعانون داخل الاحياء
والذين تعرضوا لكثير جدا من المصاعب
بصراحه
سوداويه حتى الان فيما يتعلق بالجانب
الانساني سنتحدث عنه الان من الخرطوم
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه شكرا جزيلا لك
بالفعل مشاهدينا اليونيسف افادت بان اكثر
من 13 مليون ونصف المليون طفل في السودان
بحاجه ملحه للدعم الانساني بحسب المنظمه
يعتبر هذا الرقم اعلى رقم مسجل في البلاد
في ظل زياده صعوبه تامين المساعدات
والحاجات الاساسيه اذ كان اذا كان الرقم
قبل النزاع حوالي تسعه ملايين طفل كما
اضافت المنظمه ان وضع الاطفال يصل
لمستويات كارثيه بسبب النزاع يعاني اكثر
من 620 الف طفل من سوء التغذيه الحاد
هذا بالاضافه طبعا الى عمليات النهب
والسرقه والتي اصبحت متفشيه في السودان
وذلك منذ بدايه الصراع الذي اندلع قبل
حوالي سته اسابيع هذه العمليات لا تطال
فقط المحل التجاريه وممتلكات المواطنين
ولكنها تطال ايضا المستشفيات وتحديدا تطال
المساعدات الغذائيه برنامج الاغذيه العالم
التابع للامم المتحده اوضح ان 17 الف طن
من المساعدات الغذائيه المخصصه للمحتاجين
فقدت في السودان بعض المساعدات سرقت من
مستودعات والبعض الاخر من شاحنه تابعه
للمنظمه الامميه تقدر القيمه في صوره كلفه
الطعام بما يتراوح بين 13
و14 مليون دولار مع تلقي المنظمه تقارير
يوميه بشكل تقريبي عن عمليات سرقه اخرى
المنظمه العالميه تشدد على انعدام الامن
الغذائي في السودان اصبح الان يتسبب في
اعلى مستويات القلق
على كل المزيد معنا من لندن مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للتنميه والعوني الانسانيه صادق
محمد احمد اهلا بك سيد الصادق اسمح لي ان
ابدا بقراءتك للمشهد وحجم القلق الذي
يراودكم الان
مرحبا بكم ومرحبا بالمشاهدين الكرام
الوضع الحقيقه على الارض غايه في السوق
اضافه الى ما ذكرتموه في هذه التغطيه عن
تصريح مرضى بالصحه العالميه بان هناك عدد
كبير من المعدل اللغافيه قد تم نهله
سبق المنظمه الصحه
العالميه وركزها الرئيسي في المجمع
الرئيسي
وكان هذا الكلام قبل ايام وايضا
تقارير اشارت الى ان هناك عدد كبير من
مخازن المنظمات الانسانيه فقد تم نهضه هذا
يستمر هذا الامر في ظل حاله
عدم الاستقرار الامني التي تشهدها معظم
مناطق العاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك مقر البعثات
الدبلوماسيه فرحان حقا نائبا السيد الصادق
اسمح لي ان اسال سؤال لماذا بهذه السهوله
يحدث ذلك ليس هناك من هو قادر على توفير
الحمايه على الاقل هذه المراكز وخاصه عم
نحكي عن مراكز رئيسيه
وكنت اتوقع ان يكون هناك وجود للقوات
الجيش على هذه المناطق الاستراتيجيه هذا
ما كنت اتوقع شخصيا الكثير من المراقبين
كان يجب ان يكون هناك حراسه على هذه
وكذلك على المناطق الاستراتيجيه في
الخرطوم ولكن ربما
الجيش لديه خطط عسكريه محدده اعتقد انه
يسير عليها ولكن بكل تاكيد ارسل ذلك تاثير
كبير جدا على الامدادات هناك كثير في قوات
الدعم السريع لمكاتب ومخازن المنظمات
الطبيعيه الانسانيه وتسبب ذلك في نطاق
معظم الامدادات التي كانت موجوده اصلا
سيد الصادق كيف ينعكس ذلك على دور هذه
المنظمات وهل هي قادره على تعويض ما تم
نهبه او لا
سيكون هناك صعوبه كبيره في تعويض هذه
المواد التي نهبت وذلك لان الوضع اصلا في
امداد المستشفيات والمحتاجين بهذه المواد
صعب من الخارج في الوقت الحالي الامم
المتحده قدره المحتاجين الى المساعدات
الانسانيه باكثر من
15.8 مليون شخص هذا عدا عن
او الذي يضم الاطفال ايضا الذين بحاجه الى
الرعايه خصوصا ان ذلك العدد يم
ثل
العاملين في السودان تاثروا بعمليات النهب
الذي قامت به المليشيات الامر الذي ضاع
فه كذلك وبعض
هناك
المركز في الخرطوم تم نهضه هذه الاطفال
مرض السرطان وتم نهد محتوياته وترهيبا فيه
كذلك منظمه
هناك عدد ثمانيه مستشفيات تم احتلالها من
قبل الدعم السريع في محافظه الكاملين
مستشفى الجهاد ومستشفى النوبه ومركز صحي
بانكي ومركز صحي الجديد
هذا تقرير رسم صدر اليوم عن منظمه اطباء
حول العالم باحتلالها في الدعم السريع
لهذه المستشفيات هذا الامر يزيد من
المعاناه ويزيد ذلك من صعوبه التلقي
الرعايه الطبيه في مستشفيات اصلا خرجت عن
الخدمه بصوره كبيره واصبح الطاقه يمشيها
يعاني اصلا من علاج الحالات المستعجله
والحالات الطوارئ الناتجه عن الجرحى من
العمليات الحربيه هذا عنو عن المرضى
الاخرين الذين يراجعون المستشفيات مرضى
الفشن الكلوي وغيرهم من المحتاجين الى
الرعايه الطبيه من لندن مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للتنميه والعون الانساني الصادق
محمد احمد شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات
انتهت مهمه رائدي الفضاء ريانه برناوي
وعلي القرني التي استمرت لعشره ايام في
محطه الفضاء الدوليه جرى خلالها اجراء 4
عشرات التجربه بحثيه علميه وذلك في عدد من
التخصصات حيث يغادروا بعض لحظات رائده
الفضاء السعوديين المحطه الدوليه على متن
المركبه الفضائيه دراغون يذكر ان مهمه
الفضائيه اي اكس
الدوليه يوم 21 من مايو الجاري من مركز
كندي للفضاء في فلوريدا
تقريبا وصلنا لاخر
اخر مراحل هذه المهمه الحمد لله على تمام
الحمد لله اللي قدرنا نوصل لهذا المحطه
ونقدر نخلص ابحاثنا الحمد لله
واجمل لقطات كانت انه قدرنا نتواصل مع
الطلاب ونكون جزء من التاثير اللي حيكون
عليهم باذن الله علميا نطمح باذن الله انه
نشوف رواد فضاء
سعوديين من ابناء الوطن
يجوا هنا ويشتغلوا هنا
ويحاولوا ان هم يخدموا البشريه فهذا يعني
هذا هو الهدف اللي احنا جينا عشانه والحمد
لله انه قدرنا نوصل لهذه المرحله
رسالتي انه حابه فعلا اني اشكر كل الناس
اللي ساعدونا بدايه من مقام سمو سيدي اخذ
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
ولي عهدنا
الرائد والطموح اللي يحمل كل اماننا وكل
افكارنا ورؤيتنا
طبعا لكل قصه نهايه وهذه نهايه الجزء
الاول من هذه القصه الجميله الحمدلله
اليوم اخر يوم لنا في مهمتنا العظيمه
الحمد لله انجزنا جميع المهام الموكله
الينا بنجاح وكذلك تم اجراء وانجاز جميع
التجارب العلميه والابحاث الملوطه في هذه
الرحله بنجاح ولله الحمد وان شاء الله
نسال الله ان تعود علينا بالنفع في
المستقبل وكذلك احب اشكر مقام سيدي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي عهده سمو الامير محمد بن
سلمان رئيس مجلس الفضاء على الدعم
اللامحدود الذي نحظى به وحضينا به خلال
هذه الرحله وكذلك احب اشكر جميع الجهات
التي شاركت على انجاح هذه المهمه او كل
العاملين فيها الامانه جهودكم امل موسى
ودعمكم محسوس فشكرا لكم شكرا لشعبنا
العظيم على على المشاعر اللي شاركتوها
ورايناها منكم
المزيد معنا من مركز العمليات الموحد في
الرياض مراسل العربيه هاني صفيان اهلا بك
هاني انقل لنا المشاهد
يعني مشاهداتك انت خلال تواجدك في هذا
المركز ومتى موعد المغادره تفضل هاني نعم
نعم ميسون اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه مره اخرى اذا من داخل هذا المركز
وهو مركز موحد لعمليات عوده رايدي الفضاء
ريان وعلي وتحديدا خلفي الشاشه التي تحمل
رواد الفضاون بينهم ايضا
رائدي الفضاء ريان وعلي وتحديدا ايضا من
خلف تماما هناك فنيون ومهندسون من الهيئه
هيئه الفضاء والاتصالات والتقنيه يقومون
الان في هذه اللحظات بتحليل المعلومات
وكذلك المعطيات التي تصلهم من فلوريدام
وهي المعطيات والمعلومات الاخيره
للحظات الاخيره للانفصال هذه المركبه التي
نشاهدها الان من محطه الفضاء الدوليه ولعل
الصوره التي تظهر لنا الان وهي الجزئيه او
الفاصل بين المركبه مركبه دراغون وكذلك
محطه الفضاء الدوليه هذه المركبه هناك
مراحل سوف تمر بها حتى تتمكن من
الانفصالها من المح هناك ساعات ودرجات
حراره مختلفه وسرعات عاليه حتى تصل الى
كوكب الارض عموما هذه المراحل وتفاصيلها
وكيفيه انفصالها سوف يكون معي المستشار في
هيئه في الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء وهو
المهندس ماجد المشاري مرحبا بك مهندس كنت
معنا في بدايه الانطلاق والان للعوده
لعوده هذه المركبه المركبه سوف تتم او سوف
يتم انفصالها تقريبا في تمام الساعه
السادسه وخمس دقائق بتوقيت المحلي السعودي
مراحل سوف تمر عليها ودرجات حراره عاليه
وسرعه لا نتوقعها اكثر من 28 الف كيلو متر
في الساعه
بدات اجراءات عمليه الانفصال من اكثر من
ساعه
وتشمل فصل جميع الانظمه الميكانيكيه
والكهربائيه التي تربط بين مركبه دراغون
ومحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تمهيدا للان الكامل باذن الله الساعه
السادسه وخمس دقائق بعد عمليه اكتمال الها
اجراءات الانفصال ستبدا مركبه دراغون
بالتحكم الكامل بالابتعاد عن محطه الفضاء
الدوليه باستخدام محركات الدفع وانظمه
التحكم الخاصه بها
وعند وصولها الى مسافه امنه سوف تبدا
عمليه الدوران حول الارض وفي نفس الوقت
النزول في المدار الى اختراق الغلاف الجوي
بسرعه ما يقارب 27 الف كيلو متر في الساعه
وتتعرض اثناء ذلك الى درجات حراره تصل الى
2000 درجه مئويه وفي هذه اللحظات
قد ينقطع الاتصال بالمحطه الارضيه من ست
الى سبع دقائق ثم
باذن الله فور تجاوزها لهذه المرحله
ودخولها الى الغلاف الجوي
سيتم ابطاء حركاتها بالمظلات المخصصه لذلك
سؤال الان مرحله الفصل حتى وصولها الى
الغلاف الجوي كم سوف يقضون من الوقت داخل
هذه المركبه والسؤال اخر ايضا لعله
نجاوب عليه او تجاوب عليه مع السؤال الاول
الذي سالته هل الان مرحله الصعود هناك
دوافع تدفع هذا هذه المركبه ولكن الان
العوده الدوافع فقدت او لا يوجد نتكلم عن
هذه المرحله التحليليه نعم الوقت الذي
سيقضيه رواد الفضاء الى حين اختراق الغلاف
الجوي قد يصل الى عشر ساعات تقريبا طبعا
نحن شاهدنا في رحله الانطلاق احنا
استخدمنا صاروخ لانه نحتاج انه نتحرر من
الجاذبيه لكن العكس الان راح يكون راح
نستخدم مركبه دراغون انظمه التحكم الخاصه
فيها اضافه الى الجاذبيه الارضيه اللي
ستكون الى الى
وانظمه التحكم ومحركات الدفع الموجوده في
مركبه دراغون وايضا المظلات الموجوده كلها
باذن الله ستساهم في وصول امن ان شاء الله
الى سواحل الشرقيه
شكرا لكم مهندس ماجد المشاري وهو مستشار
فيها هيئه السعوديه للفضاء وبينما ايضا
تحدث عن هذه المعلومات وتحدثنا هناك درجه
الحراره قد تصل الى 2000 درجه مئويه حتى
نزول هذه الكبسوله ايضا هنا فنيونه
ومهندسون يقومون الان بتحليل هذه
المعلومات وهذه الارقام التي ترد الى
الرياض وتحديدا من مركز الموحد من فلوريدا
الى الرياض الذين يقومون الان بتحليلها
وايضا اعطاء بعض المعطيات وبعض التعليمات
التي يقوموا بالتواصل بين رياضيات
والسلامه للجميع من مركز العمليات الموحد
في الرياض مراسل العربيه نصفيا شكرا لك
ولضيفك
قالت وسائل الاعلام ليبيا ان لجنه لجنه
سته زائد سته المشتركه من اعضاء البرلمان
وايضا من مجلس الدوله اتفقت على تشكيل
حكومه مصغره لمده سته اشهر لتنظيم
الانتخابات واشارت الى التوافق على اجراء
الانتخابات البرلمانيه في ديسمبر المقبل
والرئاسيه في يناير 20 24 كما اكدت
التقارير الليبيه ان اللجنه سمحت بترشح
العسكريين
ومزدوجي الجنسيه للانتخابات وعدم السماح
لمن عليه حكم قضائي او مطلوب للعداله كذلك
اتفقت اللجنه على تقسيم مقاعد البرلمان
لتكون المقاعد 60% للاحزاب واربعين بالمئه
للافراد
فاصل ونواصل الخامسه مشاهدينا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامس اكد وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد اللهيان
اكد ان طهران اجرت محادثات غير رسميه مع
الولايات المتحده بشان الملف النووي واوضح
في تصريحات لصحيفه الفرنسيه ان هذه
المحادثات تمت عبر وسطاء من دول المنطقه
ودول اوروبيه عبد اللهيان اشار الى انه
ابلغ وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان بامكانيه تنفيذ مشاريع اقتصاديه
بشراكه مع السعوديه كما قال ان المفاوضات
بين الاطراف اليمنيه تحرز تقدما وان طهران
تتواصل مع جميع الاطراف في اليمن لوقف
القتال والذهاب لحوار
اكد وزير الداخليه اللبنانيه بسام المولوي
ان عمليه تحرير المواطن السعودي جرت
بتنسيق بين كل الاجهزه الامنيه اشار خلال
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع السفير السعودي في
بيروت الى انه تم توقيف تسعه متورطين
بحادثه الاختطاف لدى مخابرات الجيش
اللبناني نتابع
اللبناني قام بعمليه
بعمليات تفتيش وبحث في البقاع في البقاع
الشمالي تحديدا وحتى الحدود
الحمد لله بتنسيق كل الاجهزه الامنيه تم
الوصول الى النتيجه السعيده النتيجه
المرجوه وهو تحرير المواطن الشقيق المواطن
السعودي الشقيق نحن عنا اليوم تسعه
موقوفين تسعه موقوفين موجودين لدى مخابرات
الجيش
بنتيجه هاي العمليه وبسببها
من جانبيه اطمئن السفير السعوديه لدى
لبنان وليد بخاري طمئنا ان المواطن
السعودي مشاري المطيري بخير وقد خضع
للفحوصات الطبيه اللازمه واكد حرص القياده
السعوديه على سلامه المواطن السعودي اينما
وجدت
بانه المواطن السعودي
خضع لفحوصات طبيه والحمد لله صحته بخير
مطمئن كل ذويه بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
واصدقائه ومحبيه حرص القياده السعوديه حرص
خادم الحرمين الشريفين
والسرور سيدي ولي العهد على المواطن
السعودي اينما وجد هي اولويه من اولياتها
اولويات المملكه
تشهد ولايه الجزيره وسط السودان موجه نزوح
عاليه للمرضى من الخرطوم طبعا بسبب
استمرار الحرب فيها بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع فيما اشتكى بعض المرضى
من ندره انواع عديده من جرعات السرطان في
الوقت الذي تتوفر فيه بالسوق السوداء
وباسعار عاليه نتابع صوره من داخل ثاني
اكبر مشافي العلاج الكيميائي والاشعاعي
لمرضى السرطان بالسودان
اوجاع المرضى واهات الاجساد التي تملكها
المرض العضال ازدادت بعد الحرب والسبب نقص
الادويه والضغط على المستشفى بسبب نزوح
مرضى السرطان الى ولايه الجزيره واقع تسبب
في ندره بعض الادويه وزياده اسعار الجرعات
في السوق السوداء هكذا يقول البعض
ولدنا نعلم
وقاعدين بس منتظرين عليه الله ثاني
جرعات ما في املان نهائيا خالص لكن
مؤشرات الضغط على المستشفى بدت واضحه بسبب
خروج نحو 30 مستشفى بالخرطوم عن الخدمه
الامر الذي افرز تحديات صعبه في الامداد
الدوائي وبعض المعينات كاوعيه حفظ الدم
نزحت اعداد كبيره جدا من المرضى في
اتجاهيا ولايه الجزيره في اتجاه ماركا
المعهد القومي للسرطان
ممكن مستقبلين حتى الان نحن
1723 حاله حتى اليوم
حالات جديده
ليس ببعيد عن المستشفى تستقبل هذه
الاستراحه اعدادا كبيره من مرضى السرطان
الذين لا يملكون ماوى في هذه المدينه اذ
يتم العمل على توفير الايواء والغذاء
بمجهودات شعبيه ودعم نوعي بسيط الاستراحه
على ضيقها هي الاخرى تعاني من ضغط المرضى
عندنا من تشاءات وعندنا من جنوب السودان
فداء ادى لتكدسهم وجود بالاستراحه يعني ما
بيقدروا يرجعوا اهلهم الا يطلقوا العلاج
وبرضو للاسف الشديد يعني
التقطع مال العمليه تحت العلاج انه العلاج
ما متواصل او عدم توفر العلاج فيه اوقات
كثيره ادى لوجودهم هنا داخل الاستراحه
الصوره اشد قساوه مما هو ظاهر على عدسه
الكاميرا فقدرها هؤلاء الذهاب باوجاعهم
الى مكان امن وب بعيد عن اصوات القذائف
والرصاص لتلقي الجرعات على ندرتها وي
خوضون حربا لاستعاده العافيه لاجسادهم
وبلادهم كذلك التي تعاني من مرض عضال يهدد
بقاء الدوله بانسانها وهكذا يقول البعض
محمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه ودمدني
بولايه الجزيره
الخامس انتهت شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا اب
قوا معنا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات